spending 37 seconds on a recap of two
episodes that hit
barely an hour between them we don't
have to be spoon-fed our television
especially when it would take about two
seconds to research anything we have a
question on
you would think at this point they would
know how to spell dc correctly i mean
it's two letters
this guy has terrible hand to cone
placement a bite or two of that ice
cream is going to have this dude's
finger sweat all over it
[Music]
it is not also we should absolutely sin
anytime someone hastily assembles a
swing set sure sure vision is incredibly
fast and powerful but
look if you rush these things then kids
get hurt being this excited about
spending your day with your bros
basking in books casually reading cervix
related material when you should be
watching where you're walking
we let the little ladies keep tabs on
their growing babies with fruit
makes it simple for them i'm gonna let
denae take this one
you dr dude at five months a papaya six
grapefruit
seven pineapple eight honeydew
and before i go get the [ __ ] out of here
with that excitement about
anything the size of anything taking up
space in the body and eventually popping
out especially when it's the size of a
honeydew melon shove that in your
pool [ __ ] listen
if they're keeping this a secret then
what was up with all the flaunting in
the opening credits
in fact how would those opening credits
events even occur considering she's
pregnant for less than a day before the
babies are delivered
slicing through concrete with an
electric hedge trimmer you've gotten
bigger
even in a heightened crazy scenario such
as this i feel like it's still
inappropriate to ask a woman this
question
i can't wait to be a proud
papaya dad jokes vision insinuated when
the doctor was there they just found out
wanda was pregnant 12 hours prior so
when did they go buy all the baby
furniture
having a pregnant woman around paint
fumes no matter how wonderful the
family-owned company might be
also not sure why but this paint really
makes me think about how much i prefer
last crusade over raiders
well i guess there's only one solution
to this debate
hope for a girl thinking that having a
girl will solve parental debates
if you're keeping the doll clothes on
while practicing diaper changing skills
why take off the shoes at all phil
do these earrings make me look fat
oh thank god asking if earrings make you
look fat
i think something's wrong i think
something is wrong here cliche
yes dude i think my water just broke
metaphorical amniotic showers
do you need a break i mean i feel like
you also need to help strain that dog
but
you do you i rolled my eyes when i saw
this four ounces on the luxury bath
powder box because
ounces is most often abbreviated as oz
and doesn't need the s
on the end but then my dumb ass looked
up for ocs
and that led me to this page of
scientific mumbo jumbo check it out
4ozs has synthetic construct listed here
and
so help me i can't help but wonder if
this is purposeful this show man
this show it's 75 degrees out you making
a fashion statement
says the woman wearing long sleeves in a
very fashionable vest i gotta borrow a
bucket
not to wear to use somehow all the pipes
in my ceiling burst at once pretty sure
that requires a lot more assistance than
a single bucket could provide
thank you as if geraldine wasn't acting
fishy enough with her fishy pants they
go ahead and give her an apple to be
sure we know she's an [ __ ]
here's the thing maybe geraldine does
see the stork and it's gonna be revealed
later why she's not bringing attention
to it but all i have to go on is the
present and i'm sending the
out of geraldine's peripheral vision
because it is non-existent
if she's already seen the nursery is
there really a reason to still be
covering the baby bump
bermuda awaits and my car decides to
poop out right at this
moment but you can't drive to bermuda
and you could get a cab to the airport
or cruise ship so not sure why this is a
huge issue
but stan what about my brand new
two-piece
maybe before you get comfortable sitting
in the car waiting for stan to fix it
you can hop to it and finish the packing
job
so this is all that happens when she
actually gives birth when she had a
contraction she caused all the power to
go out in the neighborhood and when she
broke her water everyone's house flooded
but when she gives birth a
vacuum turns on and the fireplace lights
up for a second and
i'm certain there should be lava
erupting and flowing in the streets
hey doc why don't you help me out in the
kitchen there
or you know stitch up some vaginal
tearing and check to be sure the
placenta comes out without issue
oh we're going to continue to gloss over
the variable parts of birth
you're strong and really clean have you
seen a baby right after it's born
there's more bodily fluids on newborn
babies than on even the most active
participants at most exorcism orgies
allow me to walk you out doctor you said
knock you out oddly and considering this
doctor represents some triggering
chauvinistic behavior i think you should
speak very clearly
well i'll go back to wonder i know
there's a strange vibe in the air but
cheese and crackers you just saw your
wife give birth to twin boys a day after
showing signs of pregnancy let's have
some priorities vision
geraldine survives this
people don't care about this they want
hard-hitting stories and in-depth
coverage and
and and twins if you've ever wanted to
know what it's like to probe into the
back end of cinema sins and learn our
deepest darkest secrets behind the sins
podcast is just what you need each week
writer is aaron that's me today
that's me and jonathan yep discuss what
it takes to create the content that you
enjoy
on youtube hopefully enjoy they probably
do i mean even if they don't we talk
about it that's true i guess i'll just
wrap this up real quick
and let you know that you can listen to
behind the scenes here on youtube
or search for the show on your favorite
podcast player yep phil
do these earrings make me look fat you
just answer
it's like a reflex do i look fat no yes
i know what you mean
if you judge your friends for passing
judgment on you you're not only judging
yourself
you're judging your friends for judging
you and that would be using bad judgment
honeydew you don't get a plus one
cantaloupe
pregnancy sucks making a human being
is really hard i have no control over my
body or my emotions scare bear i'm sorry
all i want to do is punch in the face
but i love you so much